if you are looking for some outdoor fun
i've got two words for you
lake mead take a look
[Music]
a great way to cool off this summer is
to take a dip in the lake
[Applause]
swimming in the lake is a great way to
cool off but so is tubing on lake mead
and that's what we're going to do today
with our good friend bruce nelson bruce
is always great to see you buddy yeah it
was great to see you thanks for coming
out again all right so
tubing okay let's talk about tubing what
is it do you guys rent the tube if
someone's watching they want to go
tubing so yeah you can't really rent
two but you can buy one you like start
from you know 40 or 50 dollars up to a
few hundred or more
depending on what you want to do and
it's just a great everybody can do it
you know grandma and grandpa the kids
mom and dad everybody can tube that's
the great thing about your squad have a
good time
um you need a boat you need a couple
people you need some life jackets a
ski flag and go have a good time tube
number one
what is it we got just a basic tube for
one guy or gal
the the joby revolve one now the rules
out there if i want you to go faster or
go slower any hand signals i should have
went out there in the world
you want to go faster thumbs up slower
thumbs down you want to stop
you know all right you ready here we go
get it
[Music]
yeah you did good that time how fast
were you going oh we're doing what like
30
30. yeah about 30 about 30.
30. i feel like i was doing 75. are
those bathrooms
floating bathrooms oh is that what we're
towing next uh yeah we'll just put you
right here
thank you they're actually already went
good so no i'm kidding i want to know
is that next we're doing that thing
that's that's our next ride that's the
uh we'll call it the cone
the cone how many people does the code
for and we're just gonna drag that thing
behind the boat drag that cone
standing up yeah okay four people one
two lance here number three a
photographer and the fourth guy will be
our spotter yeah
in the boat yeah how do i get on this
thing oh he's jumping hold on man
[Music]
now you okay here we go the other side
we made it that was not easy some
exhausted just from getting on
this isn't going to go well
water sports don't like mead let's go
oh my god
stay back
all right here we go here we go
okay seriously we lost lance the
photographer he was okay
i feel okay jc you're always the star of
these adventurous
segments but lance lance lance deserves
the award yeah
lance deserves a word for that one lance
went down
he a little bit of a panic attack and
realized he had the life jacket on so
all was
always fine so fun it was a waterproof
camera too by the way so everything
everything was golden if you want to
rent a boat and go tubing visit
boatinglakemead.com and
las vegas now